for full disclosure as always he has
done some legal work for me in the past
he and his wife Victoria attended my
radio show Christmas party and we did
share drinks together and we talked and
we laughed good to see you sir you too
you know so much news was made in that
interview indeed and you saw the
coverage let's start there your reaction
what does it say
what does it say to the American
consumer about the news industry in
general in this country well I think
when you take a look at the White House
Correspondents Dinner and the conduct of
the people there and when you look at
the absence of coverage of something so
major as your show last night it's
pretty clear Sean that you're right
American journalism is dead it's dying
it's in a coffin and the fact is these
people are not journalists anymore there
are people with an agenda they want to
prove something they don't want to find
something out they want to say something
on their own and this is an example of
it it's it's really a sad day a sad sad
day Joe we've had massive surveillance
abuse unmasking abuse we've had the
leaking of Raw on television telogen s--
Samantha power I'm asking a person a day
and then we have the bigger scandal Rudy
Giuliani is right Hillary committed
felonies Hillary obstructed justice
James Comey Peter struck Lisa Paige
Andrew McCabe and Loretta Lynch they
rigged that investigation then of course
with a supposed to be Trump Russia
collusion it turns out Hillary is paying
a foreign national to get use Russian
sources that turn out to be debunked and
then those that false political document
that dossier is used for a FISA warrant
to spy on an American associated with
the Trump campaign in the lead-up to an
election they're virtually silent on the
biggest abuse of power scandal in the
history of the country well I don't
think there's any doubt that that
judgment you've just made is absolutely
correct it is quite evident now that the
Muller probe is illegitimate this effort
to attempt to interview the President of
the United States has now reached the
point where there's just no doubt at all
that the president should refuse to be
interviewed by them and that's because
it's clear that the
that Muller and his team of Democratic
thugs are acting in bad faith they know
that the president under Department of
Justice rules cannot be indicted they
have no evidence to indict him
the office of Robert Muller was created
by rod Rosenstein illegally there he
mentioned no crime to be investigated
all of this leads to the ultimate
conclusion that the perpetuation of this
investigation by Muller is doing grave
damage to the United States it's doing
grave damage to United States foreign
policy it's doing grave damage to US law
enforcement because of the thug-like
tactics that have been used in the
metaphor case and in the Cohen case and
it points to something that really is
disturbing after watching the Deputy
Attorney General of the United States
Rod Rosenstein accused Congress of
trying to extort him and others in the
department by conducting legitimate
constitutional oversight I would say
that between Muller and Rosenstein and
the absent Attorney General god bless
him we have a very serious crisis in
American federal law enforcement we and
I think it's the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in our history j-rod
Rosenstein a second not so easy wrote a
letter said the FBI could never recover
if James Comey stayed at the helm so he
would be a witness on that part of it
Karev also discovered that rod
Rosenstein we talked about the the FISA
applications that relied on unverified
uncorroborated dossier paid for by
Hillary Clinton they never told the
judge it was paid for by Hillary and
then he went on to say that if you had
there are false information presented to
a FISA Court there's serious
consequences isn't he implicating
himself the same statement when he said
that he's not going to be extorted of
course the problem here for rod
Rosenstein did he has multiple conflicts
of interest he shouldn't be supervising
this case he wrote the memoranda that
led to the firing of James Comey he
signed the FISA applications
he continues to know and personally care
about Comey and Muller and others he
should be
remove from this case this is absolutely
disgraceful and now he will pretend that
he is above all of this but when all is
said and done
mr. Rosenstein represents a part of the
department that I thought we had lost a
long time ago when the Obama
administration administration people
left office but apparently they haven't
left office so we're headed for a
showdown and that is every attorney that
I know says the president should never
sit with Robert Muller Andrew Weissman
his pit bull with his atrocious track
record his team of Democratic donors
only and if the showdown goes down and
the president says no if they won't
agree to a proper written answers to
legitimate questions which I don't think
they will at this point then that means
that it's likely that Robert Muller will
then subpoena the President of the
United States before a grand jury
this is where it gets somewhat legally a
little bit tricky let's walk down that
road what happens when and what should
the response be well first of all I
think that if Muller issued a subpoena
to the president it would be an
unconstitutional subpoena since he knows
the president cannot be indicted and
since he knows that the president is not
a necessary witness to anything that he
is investigating it is clear that he
would be using the grand jury subpoena
for only one reason to get testimony
from the President to use in an
impeachment recommendation report to the
Deputy Attorney General that is an
illegal use of a grand jury subpoena the
president should resist it they should
take it all the way to the Supreme Court
because under article 2 of the
Constitution all executive power rests
in the president of the United States he
had he had ultimate authority to fire
James Comey and he did and it's a wrong
decision and of course the courts can
always be wrong we know that it's gonna
go all the way to the Supreme Court if
he issues a subpoena let me make a
prediction Muller will never issue a
subpoena why because he cannot win I
disagree with some of the comments of
Judge Napolitano earlier about the fact
that that Muller will win ultimately on
a subpoena oh let me just say this
Muller will lose ultimately on a
subpoena because it is
constitutional if it was rented and the
president pled the fifth then they would
offer him immunity and then the perjury
trap remains correct or not that is apt
technically correct but you cannot issue
immunity to someone when you are doing
it illegally under the statute because
the only reason he would be giving him
immunity would be to force testimony for
an impeachment report Muller does not
have the authority to issue an
impeachment report and he does not have
the authority to use a grand jury
subpoena to get presidential testimony
for impeachment or any other criminal
activity that never occurred because
he's dealing with the power of the
President to fire people
so if Muller wants to have that fight
and tie it up in the courts for six
months to a year he can do it but he
will be doing a grave disservice to
himself because at this point Muller has
become a cross between Madame Defarge
and Inspector Javert and it's an
embarrassment all right Jojo Jennifer
always appreciate you being on the
program